uno de los comportamientos más
importantes en los animales es el
forraje o que se refiere a la búsqueda
de alimento dentro del entorno de un
animal porque sin estabilidad no es
probable que los animales sobrevivan y
se reproduzcan pero este comportamiento
es interesante porque se asocia con algo
parecido a un análisis costo-beneficio
obviamente un animal debe de ser capaz
de hacerlo para sobrevivir pero salir y
obtener alimento realmente puede ocupar
mucho tiempo y energía así que el animal
necesita invertir energía para poder
ganarla por lo que el objetivo del
forraje gogh es siempre descubrir cómo
obtener la productividad más alta de
energía mientras se ocupa la menor
cantidad de energía haciéndolo y el
término forraje o de hecho se refiere a
bastantes comportamientos diferentes por
ejemplo puede incluir buscar alimento
como este antílope de aquí que come
pasto
pero también puede incluir acechar
presas lo que podemos ver en esta foto
donde el tigre persigue a los antílopes
hay dos estrategias de forrajeo
principales que un animal puede usar y
realmente lo que vemos que hace el tigre
en esta foto de aquí y este es el
forraje o solitario
de hecho déjame escribirlo en anaranjado
para representar al tigre el forraje o
solitario
se refiere exactamente a lo que suena es
cuando un animal busca alimento por sí
mismo el segundo tipo de forraje o que
veremos es el
forraje o
en grupo
y eso es lo que hacen los leones por lo
que lo escribiré en amarillo por aquí y
es cuando los animales buscan su
alimento en grupos y una cosa que es
tanto buena como mala de esta estrategia
es que el cazar no solo dependerá de tu
propio comportamiento sino también del
comportamiento de los que te rodean y
esto de hecho puede provocar competencia
dentro de un grupo especialmente cuando
hay escasez de recursos
pero esta estrategia también puede tener
muchos beneficios cuando muchos animales
trabajan juntos significa que los
depredadores pueden obtener presas más
grandes presas más difíciles y agresivas
así que también puede ser benéfico para
todos
en ese grupo aparte de observar las
estrategias otra pregunta que los
científicos tienen normalmente del
forraje o tiene que ver con como los
animales descubren hacerlo en primer
lugar y obviamente el comportamiento de
forrajeo está probablemente controlado
por la genética
pero resulta que la información acerca
del forraje o también puede obtenerse
por medio del aprendizaje
en los animales
por ejemplo en algunas especies como lo
son muchos tipos de primates los
miembros jóvenes de un grupo aprenden a
forraje ar observando a los adultos y
copiando su comportamiento y haciendo
esto no sólo aprenden cómo cazar sino
también qué clase de cosas deben de
cazar